do you have a moment where you stopped
trusting the media like do you remember
oh yeah but it was a long time ago how
was it tell me a yellow cake what was
that yellow cake uranium in in Iraq that
was when I was like okay because
initially like when I was young I kind
of thought Bill Clinton was cool he you
know he played sax and smoked pot and I
was like yeah that was my you know I was
a kid and so I thought he was all right
and then when when uh when it came out
that he had you know lied under oath and
stuff and impeachment I figured that he
was going to get removed from office
because the president's supposed to be
held to higher standards and then when
he wasn't I was like oh well then that
means that and this is a simple minded
take I understand but I was young that
means the Democrats are the lying party
and the Republicans are the party that
tells the truth and then we went to you
know eight years later we were in Iraq
and I'm like wait a minute they both lie
so I can't trust any of them and the
media had sold both of them as as
acceptable arguments and